go get it you got it good boy good boy
let's go let's go
this is Bronx when we found Bronx I was
just working in the office and I had
heard that we found the dog on the
street homeless no microchip matted just
dirty and left for dead almost when we
brought him to the office we had cleaned
him up I checked him out and kind of
fell in love with them at first sight
we brought Bronx to this water park
today because he absolutely deserves it
I couldn't imagine what he was going
through before he came to my wife and I
so to make up for all those lost times
he had we wanted to treat him to a nice
day of fun
once I saw him I was like let's take him
home let's bring him to the family and
and give him a better life
this is Leo and this is Charlie Charlie
Oh our rescue dogs
Charlie's more of the mastermind leo
he's more of the you know goofy
energetic dog just like that fun well we
decided to bring them to the water park
today because they bring so much
happiness and joy into our lives and you
know seeing them happy makes us happy
this is Belle she's got a dachshund pit
bull mix a co-worker of mine found her
downtown just in some bushes and was
looking for somebody to take her in so
my boyfriend and I decided to adopt her
and give her a home we took Belle here
today because it's so important for dogs
especially rescue dogs to be socialized
with other dogs I've had rescue dogs in
my house since I can remember it's
really sad how many dogs are in shelters
because nobody wants to take them in all
these dogs and the shelters are just
waiting to love somebody
that's all they want to do is to be in a
home with people that love them so they
can love them back
Oh